[Musique]
le tour d'eure-et-loir est une tour de
babel on y parle anglais allemand
italien ou même slovaque 14 des 24
équipes inscrites viennent de l'étranger
et on y trouve le futur gotha du
cyclisme mondial
l'épreuve bénéficie du parrainage de
l'uci l'union cycliste internationale
car elle remplit un rôle majeur
c'est une école de la du cycliste c'est
un stage important en balance
difficilement les coureurs dans les eaux
au niveau sans avoir passé un stage
interne isère dans ces épreuves sont
majeurs sont importantes pour autant
qu'elles s'adressent à une participation
internationale importante ce qui est le
cas ici puisque nous avons je crois 21
nationalités
[Applaudissements]
mais pour que ces futures stars se fasse
et admiré il a presque fallu un petit
miracle cette année l'édition été
maintenu au prix de très grands efforts
des organisateurs
le feu vert a été donné contre la mise
en place d'un protocole sanitaires
strictes
toutes les équipes ont été testés aux
tests pcr moins de 72 heures
voilà et don quichotte arrivé j'ai
touche apte à courir
on a même eu des tests effectués hier
matin on a fait 42 coureurs hier matin
pour des équipes qui repartent à
l'étranger dès ce soir et demain matin
donc ça c'était des complications
supplémentaires qu'on ne met pas les
autres jeunes et des efforts couronnés
par un joli succès populaire des
dizaines de spectateurs ont assisté aux
finales de l'épreuve ici à chartres
marqué par un coup double la victoire
d'étape et la victoire du classement
général pour un seul et même coureur
groupama fdj paul pineau est dans le nom
sera certainement prononcer dès la
saison prochaine
cette fois sur les plus grandes courses
professionnelles
[Musique]